(Німецькою): Мінський процес. Санкції. Луганськ. Донецьк. Кордон Росії та України.
Мінський процес, "нормандський формат"
вирішення конфлікту на Донбасі лише мирним шляхом
санкції проти Росії та невизнання анексії Криму
це складові політики щодо України
яку Меркель проводить уже більше трьох років
До того Україна лише зрідка з’являлася на порядку денному канцлерки
в контексті газових воєн між Києвом та Москвою
критики ув’язнення Юлії Тимошенко
та готовності пролікувати її в Німеччині
а також ініціативи Східного партнерства ЄС
За 12 років її канцлерства в Україні змінилися три президенти
не кажучи вже про прем’єр-міністрів
За увесь цей час вона лише один раз
відвідала Україну - 23 серпня 2014 року.
І хоча зустріч з українськими високопосадовцями тривала лише кілька годин
цей візит був дуже символічним проявом підтримки України
По-перше, це відбулося на тлі запеклих боїв на Донбасі
По-друге - напередодні Дня незалежності України
Тим часом українські урядовці були частими гостями в Берліні
Петро Порошенко за три роки свого президентства 11 разів відвідав німецьку столицю
стільки, скільки всі його попередники разом узяті
Не кажучи вже про численні телефонні розмови
або зустрічі на полях інших міжнародних майданчиків
Меркель взяла на себе чи не провідну роль
у намаганнях знайти дипломатичне рішення конфлікту на Донбасі.
Нормандський формат, Мінськ-1, а згодом і Мінськ-2
про який домовлялися рекордні 16 годин
великою мірою - її заслуга
Також Меркель докладала зусиль
аби переконати партнерів по ЄС зайняти одностайну позицію
в питанні санкцій проти Росії
Уряд Меркель на рівні різних міністерств
надає Україні допомогу з децентралізації, відбудови Донбасу
підтримки внутрішніх переселенців,
лікування поранених військовослужбовців тощо
Разом з тим позиція Анґели Меркель
щодо перспективи членства України у ЄС
відома давно: на її думку, це питання зараз не на часі
Як і питання членства в НАТО
Тим не менше Меркель висловлюється за інтенсивнішу співпрацю між Україною та Альянсом
а також активнішу євроінтеграцію України
в межах угоди про асоціацію
Тепер, коли партія Меркель - нехай і зі значними втратами
знову перемогла на виборах, політика Німеччини щодо України навряд чи зміниться
Адже канцлерку, судячи з усього, переоберуть
Деякі корективи внесуть хіба що нові ймовірні партнери
ХДС/ХСС по правлячій коаліції
Після того, як соціал-демократи після історично низьких для себе результатів
заявили, що йдуть в опозицію
нову коаліцію можуть утворити консерватори, вільні ліберали та зелені